[Music]
[Music]
atatürk establish I Sophia's and save
Joe underlined his vision of
secularizing perky and nearly a hundred
years later I think our dilemma is
trying to do the opposite
[Music]
it's not about a prayer space it's not
about building a mosque or providing for
a mosque where one doesn't that does not
exist it's rather using an issue of what
I call Muslim nationalism are
emphasizing terrific Islamic identity at
the expense of others to mobilize his
right-wing and conservative base
Jarra dominat yada yada yada yada
Banjo Kazooie Terra Cotta rivality
Yelich Army Major James an economic gain
Dola still not realism than Kazan James
Ptolemaic imaginable James Olerud canola
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we can't continue half for a mass and
half rejecting science we're absolutely
needed to clear message from the very
top of our federal government that
everyone needs to wear a mask in public
period
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a case of a man who raped his 20
month old baby who does that you know
there's obviously a sickness in the
society that has to be dealt with so
what will work how do we heal South
Africa
[Music]
South Africa has among the highest stats
in the world around GBP and violence
against women one in three women in
South Africa will experience sexual
attacks two in five women will be beaten
by their domestic partners between 30
and 40 percent of women have experienced
sexual or physical intimate partner
violence in their lifetime it's really a
society where violence has become
normalized
[Music]
women
[Music]
the Levesque hands highly traumatic past
and really what happened during that
past if you go into that history human
life did not matter it really became a
society where people became dehumanized
and I think that you know you're seeing
that a really plays a part of society
here now so for example when we do have
crime the brutality with which that
crime is perpetrated is just
mind-boggling
and it's not just the historical
background I mean there are other
factors that contribute it's not as
simple as that
it's a highly patriarchal society and in
true that historical background and
often in in many patriarchal societies
it's considered taboo to even speak
about what happens in the home we have
high levels of inequality you know post
apartheid there was an expectation that
people would now suddenly matter that
their lives would matter that they would
become you know valued citizens of this
country and that did not happen and so
you know the inequalities are absolutely
huge and get out getting worse and I
think it will really boils down to one
thing
nobody ever dealt with the
post-traumatic stress of the societies I
think this is a highly traumatized
society and nobody ever talked about it
or dealt really
it's really got to be a very
multi-layered strategy first and
foremost let's fix the justice system
you know there's no real persecutions
that take place and you know if you look
at the period between March and April
when they were like five thousand and
eighty two cases of those there were
three thousand three hundred and seventy
three arrests right and of those only
two hundred and four were ever
prosecuted so the prosecution laid rate
in this country is really low right and
the reason for that is that at the
police do not investigate these cases
for me so you know you have a case it's
very clear that you know there's a
perpetrator and they will arrest the
perpetrator but the investigation
process is extremely floors so by the
time the prosecution gets the docket
they are unable to prosecute and most of
the time these people are let out on
bail they go back and they read of them
and I think that if we start there we
start fixing the criminal justice system
if there is a deterrent if you know that
if you do this you will be prosecuted
you will not escape the net of the law
then it might act as a deterrent on the
other hand we do need to have a very
strong re-education program if you want
to call that you know where we start in
schools where we really start to really
book very openly about the history of
this country what it did what happened
and how we need to overcome it there's
got to be pros trauma counseling there's
no trust in the system that it'll
protect them they don't protect their
women and girls and I think you know the
solution is that the state actually sit
down and develop a top to bottom bottom
to up approach which really looks long
term and short term the short term is
fix the police and how they mr. gates
make sure that that cases the prosecutor
and long term start a process of healing
with society
[Music]
[Music]
Jamaica so Jamal who pays i getcha
multi-bit Dante look at Arista oh really
ought to try a new revenue check we're
leaning back just an enter the mission
you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no so far every you know we we've let
people know that it come Sunday that
some of these barriers were going to be
removed and so now this is just part of
that process the Black Hills is ours
that's where our stories began that is
our Jerusalem
my name is Simon Weymouth I am a citizen
of the Oglala Lakota Nation and I'm also
Chicano I'd asked whether or not you
think I will someday be on Mount
Rushmore
but Mount Rushmore I would believe for
the United States as a celebration of
their presidents I don't see it that way
it's a desecration of our sacred site
that's where our creation story began
and it is an unfortunately a tourist
trap but when you go there people don't
know the real history of it and now they
have four white guys right carved right
into the mountain one of them being
Abraham Lincoln who still holds the
record for you know hanging the most
indigenous people in a single day and as
calls for removal grow louder our next
guest vows to protect one of the most
iconic monuments in the world the more
we focus on the flaws of these men that
are on our Mountain the less likely we
are to recognize the virtues it's not as
easy to to tear down of course Mount
Rushmore as it is to tear down a statue
to robert e lee or christopher columbus
but i hope people begin to understand
that these were racist white men and
you're gonna have your first big
fireworks display at mount rushmore
what can burn its stone you know it's
stone that's crap
[Music]
it's still our land he's the latest
white man to come into our territory
natives are purposefully counseled out
of the conversation because you can't be
the greatest nation in the world of
you're guilty of a genocide right what
soapbox can you stand on we're the
smallest racial minority in our
ancestral land think of that
police brutality that affects indigenous
people because we're such a small
population but we're up there with with
the black community these are the
numbers and these are the facts that I
hope people will look into not just
about the desecration of our sites but
the fact that we want our land back and
you know police brutality in Indian
country indigenous women are 2.5 times
more likely to be sexually assaulted
than women of any other demographic
right so these are things that we hope
people will will learn and research and
share with others you don't want it to
be just like a short conversation about
what is Mount Rushmore what does the
Black Hills mean to indigenous people
and then they move on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
atatürk established i sopia's and seemed
to underline his vision of secularizing
perky and nearly a hundred years later I
think there no one is trying to do the
opposite
[Music]
not about a prayer space it's not about
building the mosque or providing for a
mosque where one does that does not
exist
it's rather using an issue of what I
call Muslim nationalism are emphasizing
Turkic Islamic identity at the expense
of others to mobilize his right-wing and
conservative base
Jarra Amanat yada yada yada yada
Banjo Kazooie terra cotta rivality
Yelich Army Major James an economic gain
Dola still not realism than Kazan James
Ptolemaic imaginable James Olerud canola
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we can't continue half wore a mask
and half rejecting science we're
absolutely needed to clear message from
the very top of our federal government
that everyone needs to wear a mask in
public
period
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a case of a man who raped his 20
month old baby who does that you know
there's obviously a sickness in the
society that has to be dealt with so
what will work how do we heal South
Africa
[Music]
South Africa has among the highest stats
in the world around GBP and violence
against women one in three women in
South Africa will experience sexual
attacks two in five women will be beaten
by their domestic partners between 30
and 40 percent of women have experienced
sexual or physical intimate partner
violence in their lifetime it's really a
society where violence has become
normalized
[Music]
women
[Music]
the ethic has highly traumatic past and
really what happened during that past if
you go into that history human life did
not matter it really became a society
where people became dehumanized
and I think that you know you're seeing
that a really planes about in society
here now so for example when we do have
crime the brutality with which that
crime is perpetrated is just
mind-boggling
and it's not just the historical
background I mean there are other
factors that contribute it's not as
simple as that
it's a highly patriarchal society and
into that historical background and
often in in many patriarchal societies
it's considered taboo to even speak
about what happens in the whole we have
high levels of inequality you know post
apartheid there was an expectation that
people would now suddenly matter that
their lives would matter that they would
become you know valued citizens of this
country and that did not happen and so
you know the inequalities are absolutely
huge and get out getting worse and I
think it will really points down to one
thing
nobody ever dealt with the
post-traumatic stress of the societies I
think this is a highly traumatized
society and nobody ever talked about it
or dealt with it it's really got to be a
very multi-layered strategy first and
foremost let's fix the justice system
you know there's no real persecutions
that take place and you know if you look
at the period between March and April
when they were like five thousand and
eighty two cases of those they were 3373
arrests right and of those only 204 were
ever prosecuted so the prosecution laid
rate in this country is really low right
and the reason for that is that the
police do not investigate these cases
probably so you know you have a case
it's very clear that you know there's a
perpetrator and they will arrest the
perpetrator but the investigation
process is extremely floors so by the
time the prosecution gets the dockets
they are unable to prosecute and most of
the time these people are let out on
bail they go back and they read of them
and I think that if we start there if we
start fixing the criminal justice system
if there is a deterrent if you know that
if you do this you will be prosecuted
you will not escape the net of the law
then it might act as a deterrent on the
other hand we do need to have a very
strong re-education program if you want
to call that you know where we start in
schools where we really start to really
book very openly
about the history of this country what
he did what happened and how we need to
overcome it there's got to be pros
trauma counseling there's no trust in
the system that it'll protect them that
will protect their women and girls and I
think you know the solution is that the
state actually sit down and develop a
top to bottom bottom to up approach
which really looks long-term and
short-term the short term is fixed the
police and how they mr. gates make sure
that that cases the prosecutor and long
term start a process of healing with
society
[Music]
[Music]
Jamaica so Jamal who pays i getcha
multi-bit dante wookie turista
artichokia revoluta sequela noon van
Gogh just invented the mission you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no so far every you know we we've let
people know that it come Sunday that
some of these barriers we're gonna be
removed and so now this is just part of
that process the Black Hills is ours
that's where our stories began that is
our Jerusalem
my name is Simon Wayne Smith I am a
citizen of the Oglala Lakota Nation and
I'm also Chicano I'd asked whether or
not you think I will someday be on Mount
Rushmore
but Mount Rushmore I would believe for
the United States as a celebration of
their presidents I don't see it that way
it's a desecration of our sacred site
that's where our creation story began
and it is an unfortunately a tourist
trap but when you go there people don't
know the real history of it and now they
have four white guys right carved right
into the mountain one of them being
Abraham Lincoln who still holds the
record for you know hanging the most
indigenous people in a single day and as
calls for removal grow louder our next
guest vows to protect one of the most
iconic monuments in the world the more
we focus on the flaws of these men that
are on our Mountain the less likely we
are to recognize the virtues it's not as
easy to to tear down of course Mount
Rushmore as it is to turn down a statue
to Robert Evie or Christopher Columbus
but I hope people begin to understand
that these were racist white men and
you're gonna have your first big
fireworks display at Mount Rushmore
what can burn its stone you know it's
stolen that's correct
[Music]
it's still our land is the latest white
man to come into our territory natives
are purposefully counseled out of the
conversation because you can't be the
greatest nation in the world of your
guilty but genocide right what soapbox
can you stand on we're the smallest
racial minority in our ancestral land
think of that
police brutality that affects indigenous
people because we're such a small
population but we're up there with with
the black community these are the
numbers and these are the facts that I
hope people will look into not just
about the desecration of our sites but
the fact that we want our land back and
then you know police brutality in Indian
country indigenous women are 2.5 times
more likely to be sexually assaulted
than women of any other demographic
right so these are things that we hope
people will will learn and research and
share with others you don't want it to
be just like a short conversation about
what is Mount Rushmore what does the
Black Hills mean to indigenous people
and then a move
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
atatürk established i sopia's and ZM to
underline his vision of secularizing
perky and nearly a hundred years later I
think there no one is trying to do the
opposite
[Music]
not about a prayer space it's not about
building the mosque or providing for a
mosque where one doesn't that does not
exist
it's rather using an issue of what I
called less of nationalism are
emphasizing Turkey's Islamic identity at
the expense of others to mobilize his
right-wing and conservative base
Jarra Amanat yada yada yada dilution
banjo kazooie terracotta rivality
Yelich Army Major James Nikolic Jane Doe
Leslie naturalism
dan Kazan James Ptolemaic imaginable
James Olerud Carmela
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we can't continue half for a mast and
half rejecting science we're absolutely
needed clear message from the very top
of our federal government that everyone
needs to wear a mask in public period